oh yes he circles like a speaking hello
this is Adam Smith calling my
congratulations on the award of the
Nobel Prize Thank You Vicki how did you
hear the news how did you know I was
working with my voice at the major
university I was just arranging my
papers and second sound document yes at
the telephone rang I hear from the Nobel
foundation about 6pm insert the other
surprises what was your reaction your
first reaction oh I was a woman helped
by the Fuma interviewer and then message
of complications so in Congress NDC I
feel this shows the authority and the
greatness of a Nobel Prize indeed I
imagine everybody wants to talk to you
now the airhead tell me one of your co
laureates hero she amano he was your
graduate student yeah I talked to him
what is he saying uh congratulation he
killed how very nice you were the
pioneer of the blue LED oh I think oh
yes and how did you have the courage to
try to develop it when nobody else could
in the late nineties lead on the row
green LEDs and infrared conductor is had
two already being the broad but there
was no prospect of practical blue light
emitters even the MPS so a fire too many
researchers including frontrunners
agaram nitro abandon dezer development
okay